hey this is press to
Walker the Sydney Morning heral reports
the question on the final page of the
most challenging HSC math exam is famed
for its difficulty intended to stretch
the state's most talented maths students
beyond their comfort
zone the story was also picked up across
other news sites so what was this
difficult
question the complex numbers w and z
both have modulus 1 and Pi / 2 is less
than the principal argument of Z over W
Which is less than Pi or Capital AR
denotes the principal
argument for real numbers X and Y
consider the complex number XZ + YW all
over
Z on an XY plane clearly sketch the
region that contain contains all points
X comma y for which Pi / 2 is less than
the principal argument of XZ + YW all
over Z and this needs to be less than
Pi I think Professor Fox and Mr humble
for sending me this
suggestion so this is a completely
intimidating question and even when I
read it I was completely confused over
what you're supposed to do so I tried to
find some solutions online but I didn't
really understand their Solutions I
haven't been through the Australian
education system but I'm just going to
present how I would approach this
problem so for quick review let's look
at the complex plane where we have a
real axis and an imaginary axis a
complex number Z is equal to a plus bi I
if we put this point over here we can
also write it in polar form so we have a
circle we have this line here which will
be the radius length and we have an
angle Theta so we can also write this
number as r multipli e to power of I
Theta now of course you can add any
multiple of 2 pi to this so you can also
have many different representations of
this number but we don't want to deal
with all of these multiples we just want
to deal with the principal angle so it
will just be this
angle
now the radius is also equal to the
absolute value of Z which is also known
as the modulus of Z and the angle Theta
is also referred to as the argument of Z
in this case it's the principal angle so
this is also the principal argument the
principal value so we can also write
this as the modulus of Z multiplied e to
the power of I multiplied by r z
so now let's approach the
problem we have the argument of a number
Z over W so let's just say Z over W is
the number we're looking at so we have
the complex plane and we're plotting
this point Z over W in the second
quadrant and we know it's in the second
quadrant because the angle is between Pi
/ 2 and
Pi so the point is over here and the
angle will be equal to the argument of Z
over
W now what is the modulus of Z over W
it's equal to the modulus of Z divided
by the modulus of w but both Z and W
have modulus 1 so this is 1 over one
which is equal to one so we know that
the modulus of Z over W is equal to one
this is a radius equal to 1 so we can
write z over W in polar form as e to the
power of I Theta this is for Theta
between Pi / 2 and
Pi now let's go to the next step of the
problem for real numbers X and Y
consider the complex number XZ + YW all
over
Z let's simplify this fraction we'll
split this up into two fractions then in
the first fraction the Z's will cancel
out so we have x + y * W over Z W over Z
is the reciprocal of Z over W so this is
equal to 1 / e to the I Theta and that
is equal to e to the minus I Theta let
this entire complex number be denoted as
V now let's expand out e to the I thet
we can write this as cosine of thet plus
I I * sin of
thet cosine of a negative angle is equal
to cosine of that angle and S of
negative an angle is opposite of that so
this is equal to x + yti cosine Theta
minus I sin Theta distribute the Y and
now let's group real parts and imaginary
parts so we have x + y cosine Theta
that's the real part minus I multiplied
by y sin Theta that's the imaginary part
we'll just write it in the form a + bi I
so I'll write this as x + y cosine Theta
+ I * y * sin
Theta now we want to know where the
argument of this number is going to be
between Pi / 2 and Pi so we exactly have
made this number equal to V and we need
to figure out where the argument of V is
between Pi / 2 and pi and we need to
sketch all such points X Y that this is
true so how can we do
that so in order for this number to have
an argument between Pi / 2 and Pi we
will need the number V to be in the
second
quadrant now in the second quadrant we
will have exactly the real part is going
to be a negative number and the
imaginary part must be a positive number
so we need to make these two things
happen now for an angle that's between
Pi / 2 and Pi s of theta is greater than
zero so in the imaginary part s of theta
is positive and we need this entire term
to be positive so negative y needs to be
positive which means that y needs to be
less than zero so so that the opposite
of Y is greater than zero now let's look
at the real
part in this range of Pi / 2 to Theta to
Pi cosine of theta is less than zero so
this is negative now we also know that Y
is negative so negative time a negative
is going to be a positive but we need
the entire real part to be negative so x
+ y cosine Theta needs to be less than
zero so we'll solve this for y so if X
is less than- y cosine Theta cosine
Theta is negative so we're going to
divide through and that will flip the
inequality so x / cosine Theta will be
greater than y we'll multiply both sides
by 1 which will flip the inequality
again Sox / cosine Theta is less than y
and we figured out our conditions now
all we need to do is sketch it in the XY
plane so let's Gra graph the line Y is
equal tox / cosine thet so what kind of
slope will this line have well we havex
so you would think it's a negative slope
but cosine of theta is also less than
zero so two negatives will make a
positive and this line will have a
positive slope it will go through zero
because when X is0 Y is equal to
Z Now Z over W is equal to e to the I
Theta so Theta is the argument of Z over
W so we'll just label this line as Y is
equal tox / cosine of the argument of Z
over
W finally we need y to be less than zero
and it also needs to be greater than
this line so that's exactly this region
right here in the third quadrant and
that's the answer this is an extremely
difficult question to even understand in
a timed exam setting I would be very
impressed to see how many students were
able to solve this
question thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time